you need good starting pitching to go
along with that for a team to get a
string of wins together so it's up to
quan young kim to be good here tonight
3.31 era you know in today's baseball
that's pretty darn good
from two to a full count swinging a miss
or did he get a piece
yadi thinks that
he is out and whitmerfield is trying to
point out that he got a piece of it
now you can ask
for the
other umpires to come in and help you
out with this call but this is not
something that would be reviewable
i wonder if he's actually saying the
count's wrong too he put his two fingers
up because i don't think he did
tip that ball
we look at it on the replay and not 100
sure but i i wonder if it's a count
question we held up two fingers
with two outs and a runner at second
base outfield is straight away round
ball two hops to pull the young
and the strike to goldie
the royals will strand a runner
and the bottom of the first is coming up
and it's 1-0 so keller's last time out
and you look at his numbers last time
out he only went three innings and had a
lower back stiffness and had to come out
he gave up seven hits in three innings
so a chance here for yadier molina
runners at second and third and two outs
molina with the fly bowling to right
battling the sun dozier it does come
into play
the ball drops
and the cardinals will pick up a first
inning lead
we were talking about it would it come
into play it has and it's two-nothing st
louis
two on with two out and michael taylor a
veteran coming up base hit left field
here comes hunter dozier
the throw is cut off and the royals are
on the scoreboard cutting the cardinal
lead to two to one
[Applause]
so taylor comes through
the royals within one
rivera moving to second base in the play
and now you've got a guy who
historically has been outstanding it's
against lefties in his career
shot to left base hit rivera comes
around third the throw to the plate is
not held onto by molina and rivera
scores to tie the game make the walk
hurt beautiful
alberto you know didn't line it out he
hit the top and this throw had molina
found the handle on it it probably would
have gotten him worried about rivera
though that he twisted his ankle right
here this was tough getting out of the
way
gotti comes up in the line like that
and
you know if the catcher's in the way
there you don't have to alter yours he
twisted his right ankle i saw that
the young with a high fly ball into deep
right field
off the wall
and paul de young trotting into second
standing up
with a one-out double here in the home
half of the fourth
little flare into center de young on his
way to third and to make sure it got
down
and the runners at first and third with
one out
carpenter hits it down the right field
line that ball is down off the wall one
run will score they're going to wave him
in
relay to the plate he is safe no they're
going to call him out edmond it looked
like he avoided the tag but perez got
him and with that one run does score to
make it a 3-2 cardinal lead
that's the way to hit that
relay man with mere field
whit put a really good throw on it
strong throw one hopper so one out and
here is arnotto
high fly ball did he get enough it's at
the wall gone
nolan goes deep
coronado's 22nd
and the fans on this saturday night
they're loving it
4-2 cardinals
the 3-2 pitch
up the middle
past
and into center field
the young on base for the third time is
mayerfield
i think he thinks he should have had it
the young is running base head off the
glove of the first baseman santana
and the young will wind up at third
runners at the corners and nobody out
for st louis
the 2-2
oh get the candy bar
get them rolling it's a base hit to left
off the bench mars new bar and listen to
the crowd
and i'm not sure but i think he might
have taken a bite out of a newt bar
right after he rounded first base
hope you saw him do that
he was pretty amped up about that hit
why not
carlson base hit into left
here comes edmond no they're going to
hold him up the throwback behind it
third back in safely bases loaded
ground ball short
across the diamond in time so starmont
wiggles out of a bases loaded no out jam
the royals do give up a run it's 5-2 st
louis
little flair into shallow right in a
base head how about the cardinal pinch
hitters tonight carpenter rbi double
then he had lars newpar rbi single
rondon a base hit to right not a strike
[Music]
nice
angel hernandez first base umpire with
his nose right in there on that call
salvi says
take that yachty
quick as always with that left-handed
batter up that runner can't see the
catcher too well and he gets on one knee
a perfect throw i mean that ball is
right on the base and the right hand of
centennials he got to do is just put it
on him
and angel hernandez is right there let's
see if he didn't sneak his head in there
or not
oh man he barely held onto that baseball
shirt oh my god let's see what new york
has to say
the umpires rotate
into out of new york city so they can do
the man the
replays
oh yeah
can't overturn it's too good way to go
salvi
nice job
the story in this game though has been
the bullpen of the cardinals kk gave
them four and since then the bullpen has
allowed just one hit
giovanni gallegos chevy called to the
pin fly ball
right field
carlson there
knows when it five to two and they're
back at 500
55 and 55 they win the
series and now tomorrow they'll look for
a sweep against kansas city